good morning believe nation my name is
Evan Carmichael my one word is believe
and I believe that entrepreneurs will
solve all of the major problems of the
world
so today's message is be your real self
over to you Merrill Street the point
senior year when my adjustment felt like
me I I had actually convinced myself
that I was this person and she me pretty
talented but not stuck-up you know a
girl who laughed a lot at every stupid
thing every boy said and who lowered her
eyes at the right moment and deferred
who learned to defer when the boys took
over the conversation I really remember
this so clearly and I could tell it was
working I was much less annoying to the
guys than I had been they liked me
better and I liked that this was
conscious but it was at the same time
motivated and fully fully felt this was
real real acting I got to Vassar which
43 years ago was a single sex
institution like all the colleges and
what they called the Seven Sisters the
female Ivy League and I made some very
quick but lifelong and challenging
friends and with their help outside of
any competition for boys my brain woke
up
I got up and I got outside myself and I
found myself again I didn't have to
pretend I could be goofy vehement
aggressive and slovenly and open and
funny and tough of my friends let me I
wash my hair for three weeks one they
accepted me like The Velveteen Rabbit
I became real instead of an imaginary
stuffed bunny what has been a really
bring home for me is how important the
environment you have is the people
around you how much they impact your
beliefs your actions the way you think
and just by being around different
people you can become more of yourself
if you're around people who are playing
a big game you're going to want to play
a bigger game if you're on people who
are thinking small and complaining
chances are you're going to think
smaller and complain a lot more and so
paying close attention to the people who
you're surrounding yourself with really
really really really really really
really really really really matters
there's the age-old expression of you
are the result of the five people who
you hang out with and it's true so it's
a quick example from my recent history I
came back from a conference in Palm
Springs called clammer con which is for
youtubers with a hundred thousand plus
subscribers and I met two interesting
youtubers who I'd known before on email
but I got a chance to interact with them
the first was Charlie from charisma
command he's got a great channel talking
about how you can be more charismatic
one of the things that Charlie really
liked about me was my ability to network
with people in the room and make
introductions of people to the point
where he made a video on his channel
talking about it
so last week I kind of had my mind blown
and it's because I went to an event and
I learned more there about networking
that I've learned in my entire life
previous to that event and what was
really weird is that I learned it from
an introvert so I'd always expected that
extroverts like myself would have an
easier time networking because we're
more comfortable in groups more
comfortable talking for long periods of
time with strangers but quite frankly
this guy blew me out of the water his
networks far exceeded mine it felt like
almost every time that I mentioned
something I was interested in he's like
oh
yeah I know someone who could do that I
can introduce you to them and then after
the event he did one of the things I
love they both Charlie was how healthy
he was and every time we went out he's
ordering healthy food salad salmon and
I'm sitting there eating pizza and junk
and so here's what happened if we spent
more time together if we were in close
proximity more than just once a year at
this event then I guarantee you he would
become better at networking and making
introductions and talking to people and
I would start getting more fit and more
healthy and more conscious of what I was
eating and working out more because
we're in each other's environment the
second person is Antonio who runs a
channel called real men real style and
he was really impressed at how I was
pushing him to want to make a video a
dance you got to make more videos on
your channel if you want to send out
YouTube wants a video a day you got to
go daily on your channel to the point
where he wanted to make a video about it
as well and the one thing the one word I
took from Evan is impact this guy is
wickedly smart he's one of the few
people out there that I can be having a
conversation with and realize he's more
intense than me and he can turn the
situation so that you find you're
agreeing with him literally he had me
agreeing that I should probably be
putting out one video a day when I was
hanging around and Tony I was always
impressed by his style and he was talk
to me about fragrances and smell is it
starts to you know make me think of
maybe what I should be doing more in my
life and so we were spending more time
together in close proximity beyond just
once a year he would be making more
daily content it would happen I would
will it into existence for him and he
would be pushing style advice on me and
fragrance and scent and all the things
that he's working on and the more we
spend time together the more woods come
together on those kinds of issues and so
the people that you spend your time with
really really really matter now how do
you know if you have the right
environment the answer is start asking
yourself about the genes you have the
big goals you have the mission at your
on the big thing that you want to
accomplish what's the reaction of the
people close to you when you tell them
your plan here is my dream of what I
want to be mom and dad best friend you
know teacher professor neighbors what's
the reaction are people supportive are
people encouraging are people trying to
offer resources and how
my ideas on how to make it better are
people apathetic and they don't care
our people negative and telling you that
you can't do it are you even afraid just
to bring up the subject to them because
you know what their immediate reaction
is going to be if that's the environment
that you're in you need to switch right
if you are afraid to bring up your ideas
to the people around you because you
know it's just going to be negativity
then you need to switch your environment
as long as you're around those people
you will never do great things and then
you might see what Evan I don't know
great people I don't know how to change
my environment I'm stuck with these
people it's my family it's my friend so
you know you're right to some extent
then your family they're your friends
one you can limit your exposure you also
spend as much time with them you can
only talk about certain things with them
and then too you can design the
environment it may be going to event
finding places like climber colonies for
me as a youtuber finding other events
finding local things that you don't have
to travel and spend a lot of money to go
to finding local people club meetup
groups like-minded people to hang out
with and spend time with it could be
aspiration lament or that's where I
learned most of my stuff from the top
tens of people who I look up to done
amazing things the more time you spend
hanging around people like Steve Jobs
that Elon Musk and Oprah Winfrey listen
to their advice and how they take and
how they talk and how they deal with
situation the more time you spend
hanging around them and the less time
you spend hanging around these negative
people the more you're going to be like
that you're going to gravitate there
you're going to believe in your big
ideas you're going to accomplish bigger
things you're pulled in that direction
your environment is so so so so
important and so the question of the day
today is I'm curious what does your
environment look like are they full of
positive optimistic people helping you
apprehend people who don't really care
or negative people who tell you that you
can't do it really curious to find out
leave it down the comments below thank
you for sharing I also want to give a
quick shout out to Sue's then I've been
on Lobos thank you so much to Donna for
picking up a copy of my book your one
word it really really really means a lot
to me and I hope you're enjoying the
read so thank you guys again for
watching I believe in you I hope you
continue to believe in yourself and
whatever your one word is and I'll see
you again tomorrow morning for another
shot events Press
I wake spray bulky me go
I haven't had any regrets you know and
it there in it sometimes really hard
I'll tell you a funny story I remember
right before I got a different world I
auditioned for blossom remember the TV
shop hallelujah you remember her friend
the young girl her six I auditioned for
six okay
and I had my hair up in little ponytails
this little jumpsuit I look like I saw
12 got the role okay
got the role to play six and I was like
I was 18 19 years old and I said it I
looked at my agent Nancy Rainford I said
Nancy I can't do this I just can't do it
this is I'm going to be miserable
playing a 12 year old on this show I
can't do this and we had to turn it down
and I and let me tell you them folks
were not happy it's like this girl is
she is convicted all that whole thing
but within two weeks I got a different
world and that really taught me a lesson
which was you know to really listen to
and follow my gut because everything
that that shines isn't gold you know
what I mean and so it really taught me a
very valuable lesson to just stay true
to myself if there's nothing that I
haven't learned about this business it's
really about staying true to why I'm
here why you know I started acting in
the first place and and what's important
to me and keeping my artistic integrity
as well as my creative like my personal
integrity and that was a big lesson for
me and let me tell you that was not an
easy thing to turn down you know being a
young actress you got this opportunity
for you know this series regular is
money you know but I just felt deep it
down inside I was like something's
coming your way just fall back and then
I got to meet you know Debbie Allen
I said look why why don't we change
everything up is a boost me be myself
just me Jackie Chan that takes a lot of
confidence
yeah I'm building and also I really
thank you you know the producer whistle
he said okay do whatever you like to do
yeah change no Bruce Lee harmony when
Bruce Lipton hi I think love work when
Bruce Lee after punch I just
Wow no just like normal human being
normal when I was young I'm fighting on
the street one by one
oh my knock somebody down to buy one
that saw somebody down three I run away
so in the movie do the same thing
I just everything used in the movie use
my it's my real life when she was 17
years old Stephanie got her high school
diploma and left the nuns to join the
prestigious Tisch School of Arts a
school entirely dedicated to artistic
disciplines
she took numerous classes such as arts
story music theater and dancing I was
really blessed and lucky to get in I got
in very early I was 17 and I was one of
20 people in in America that got into
the school early and I was really happy
and excited and I just felt like all my
dreams were coming true and it was a
wonderful school but it was very factory
like not in the Warhol factory like way
more like a sausage link factory where
everyone was taught the same sorts of
things and and I think what I didn't
like about the school was I felt that
they wanted us all to be the same and
possess the same skills and I had
something very different inside of me